- vous pour tout votre carrière vous
vous magnifique aujourd'hui
merci ça et là franchement vous êtes
fait coiffer maquiller oui bah non
d'accroître la prochaine fois mais il
s'est entraîné au paddle ce week-end
tout le week-end d'accord très bien même
ce match est un tournoi
hier j'ai gagné avec mon ami stéphane
souvent d'accord on a gagné le tournoi
j'ai rejoué la bouée hurricanes ont donc
y ramener la coupe à la maison quoi aux
eaux
voilà donc je vais vous le dire tiens ça
me fait penser sans confiance ça vous
fait pas peur et coûteux si vous gagnez
sur la tête de ma mère je ne rigole pas
je fais l'émission entièrement à white
n'ont pas un bon rennes minton aussi
vous le fera pas une amie pour rien
allez on t'appelle tu t'appelais milieu
de semaine je t'appelle on parle l'une
des meilleures raquettes pas eu
il sera prêt qu'en quinze jours en plein
jour je viens en à moi en à moi tu vas
donc arriver à juguler un écart de dix
ans exactement
et bah écoutez bravo strauss kahn ques
il est sûr de lui et est toujours sûr de
lui vous gardez votre partenaire par
contre high and we were lauriane je
voulais dire c'est mon pote à moi c'est
le seul gars étaient courbés rumeur qui
court vers une balle tu as l'impression
qu'ils craquent
sans déconner j'ai cru que ma story
vais-je enlever la carène j'ai vu qu'il
avait une boule dans la cour ils volent
jets privés et les vallées alpines et de
quelques mailles
il anime le retour à lundi ça fait
plaisir au téléphone ce week-end elle
m'a raconté plein de choses allaient
très amoureuse
amoureuse de la vie et enfin castaldi à
environ pour un beau gosse dans les
loges ils arrêtent pas de passer comme
ça des crampons à plein d'une logique et
enfin je suis très heureux d'accueillir
quelqu'un que j'aime depuis très
longtemps
sylvie boulet qui nous rejoint dans
l'équipe
mon chéri tu vas voir ici rien n'est
préparé à travailler mon cv
non si j'ai travaillé je sais qu'il ya
travaillé bah tu verras tu conscience
très vite tu fera comme les autres c'est
toujours je suis très content de ce pas
mais moi aussi je suis ravie j'ai qu'un
truc à dire amuse toi fais toi plaisir
mais voilà il regarde voilà tu vois là
tu as des gens venus de tous les
horizons
c'est vrai mais c'est à même de mettre
des gens qui sont décédés qui sont
encore là-bas